the next three talks will be related to
[Laughter]
the people I work with are two of them
offered a did their work at the research
group called safe track which worries
about safety and translation alex
kuchenski works at the path which is
Institute for translation and Link Cal U
is a graduate student in translation she
works on demand modeling but first
question you might ask is what why
intersections and not other things and
so that's the reason why intersections
so they are as I put it small killing
fields and a huge number of accidents
and fatalities occur in two sections
which sort of maybe 5% of the road
system is small but has a
disproportionate number of accidents
fatale these years accidents so on and
so and so that's some things then the
second bullet is just two that you all
experience red light running that they
caused about 165,000 accidents and seven
to eight hundred fatalities each year so
why are intersections such a
concentration of accidents and
fatalities and that's the next blue Kong
that they have complex geometry as you
can see in the left they have complex
operating rules as you can see in that
timing diagram and with all those arrows
and their signs are complicated alright
so these three things make it difficult
to navigate through the intersection the
reason that the fatalities are low
compared to the proportion of crashes is
because they're low speed right if all
these people travel at 40 miles per hour
and then the fatalities would be three
four or five times more than
so the promise of armored vehicles
that's what I want to discuss so the
first quote there is from way moe that
is used to be Google and you have 1.2
million lives lost around the world each
year in traffic accidents and 94 percent
involved human error and our technology
is going to take care of that and so
we're gonna save thousands of lives
that's the way Moe the next one is from
GM they have a company called cruise
which does automated vehicles for GM and
they have the same quote except the
number of dead people are higher in GM
1.25 has a post 1.2 but the report is
one year later and 40,000 in the US
alone that's too inflated and human
error is a major contributing factor and
our vision is zero crashes so that's the
promise made by automated vehicle
manufacturers so what does automated eco
what is that technology depend on and so
there's a simplification that depends on
deep learning and simulation the first
quote is from Iran musk who says if you
solve vision you've solved automation if
you haven't saw vision if you haven't
solved automation so that's Musk's
belief about how Tesla's will work
because they've solved the vision
problem and then you can drive way more
a little bit more sedate so they have
driven three and a half million
real-world miles autonomously and they
predict the intentions of other agents
which obviously is not just from the
vision but they visualize everything
they see and they simulate the hell out
of everything so every time they have an
incident they have 20,000 simulations
person Aereo and you wonder what in the
world they do and they do something
called fuzz which is they suppose you
have ten objects in there and you just
perturbed them so many times you can
easily get 200,000 right 20,000 so
that's their approach and you can read
all that in the safety report just for
comparison u.s. statistics is 100
million vehicle miles per fatality and
1.2 million vehicle miles per crash
okay open jury rather so let's look at
the safety record so way more so this is
very difficult to get right what is the
safety record of autonomous vehicles but
in California the the companies that do
testing have to report an annual report
something called a disengagement report
and a disengagement report is every time
the safety driver took over from the
autonomous driving right and he took
over because of the things written that
the safety significance and according to
Google or Remo the engineer should pay
attention to what happened and so they
disabled the automated vehicles right so
that's a disengagement report in fact
there are thousands hundred times more
disengagement reports but these are the
ones that way more reports to the
California DMV saying that there is a
safety issue so I'm assuming that that
means that if that operator had not
intervened that might lead to a crash so
then you can compare the vemos record of
five thousand miles per disengagement
with you and driving which is between
200 and 500 thousand miles human driving
between crashes all right so currently
if you take that estimate or even if you
finish late and make it ten times as
then it's fifty thousand miles per crash
in a way more car versus 200 to 5,000
miles driving with you so that's the
contest there's a long ways to go and I
haven't put down the latest thing which
is that there was a goober armored
vehicle which killed somebody
right now I'm gonna analyze why these
accidents occur and I'm gonna take as an
example an uber crash an uber automated
vehicle crash in Tempe Arizona
that's where also the accident occurred
and just to go through what's going on
so on the bottom left is the police
report so you can see there's three
lanes going from north to south plus a
turn lane alright so you can see the
turn lane is marked by the arrow and
there's three lanes going up and a turn
lane
okay so what happened on that particular
date there's a driver coming here and
making a turn goober vehicle is going
straight down these two lanes are
blocked there's traffic there right and
there's saturation so they blocked on
the other side it's locked here but this
lane is clear and so the uber vehicle
goes at 38 miles per hour in a 40 mile
per hour zone
and it enters this thing when the light
is yellow all right which is okay I mean
you're allowed to do that and that's
according to Ober that's there because a
program that way that if it's yellow it
assumes it's green it drives as if it's
green not assumes it's green this
vehicle went through and saw these two
who were blocked it stops over here it
doesn't see anybody coming down here so
proceeds and all of a sudden this
vehicle comes and crashes into it after
the uber crashes it's growing at 40
miles per hour
this vehicle is growing about five miles
an hour it's it's a pole flips on its
side hits two other vehicles and that's
the end result that's the uber automated
vehicle those are the other two park
vehicles
unfortunately in the way of the uber
okay so the question is what well this
is an animation of what happened
so on the left is what the left turning
vehicle sees and on the right is what
the uber sees so the left turning
vehicle goes there comes to a stop
doesn't see anybody and then proceeds
and it's easier to see on the top you
see the uber goes straight the other
vehicle turns and then they meet so what
happens is neither one sees the other so
let's look at the lessons from this
crash so the AI as far as I can tell
there were at least four errors you
might call unforced errors so the
spatial and temporal uncertainties the
first one the uber did not know that the
traffic and the opposing lane could turn
left all right I mean there's no way for
you know all it sees its own light red
yellow green doesn't know what the other
vehicle is what kind of light it has so
doesn't know that secondly it did not
predict that the light will become
yellow is going at 40 miles an hour and
then the light becomes yellow and it
just goes through if it knew that it
might have slowed my slow down I don't
know then the uber operator saw the
Honda but had no time to react that's
the code from the operator
that's traffic in the first two lanes on
his left I've created a blind spot so
couldn't see that left turning the Honda
driver and that's a quote from her he's
about to cross the third lane so first
cross the first two lane the cars a
partner about the third the third and
suddenly saw a car flying through the
intersection but couldn't break fast
enough to stop so those are the four
errors so it could have been prevented
if some information were provided to
these two drivers what are the
information so the crash may have been
prevented by providing phased prediction
so you could have told that the phase
this light is gonna turn yellow in five
seconds four seconds three seconds two
seconds and then you might have
responded to that by stopping the phase
would have also told the uber that a
left turn in front of the car is
permitted
didn't know that so that's another
possibility then there's a blind spot
information so the the other vehicle was
in a blind spot which is temporarily
created by the two obstacles next to the
uber so if the blind spots occupied
message had been given to the uber that
could have prevented and similarly
there's a blind spot information to the
Honda that there's a vehicle coming in
the lane that you cannot see but there
is a vehicle there coming that that
might have stopped so all this
information can be provided by the
intersection but an automated vehicle in
its sensors there's no way to get that
information right so the answer the the
thing I want to say is that if we had
intersections which provide information
then that could avoid these sorts of
accidents now that's an azimuth who
automated vehicle manufacturers they
want all their intelligence to be self
contained in the vehicle they do not
want to rely on anything the public
provides them right so that's a big
issue yes
no this turning left this is so it's not
it's no it's the left it's a correct
place to go that you there's a different
issue you would say as a traffic
engineer is how in the world Tempe
permits so-called permissive left turns
in a 40 mile per hour zone that's not
not permitted by code but in Arizona is
sort of free West Country what other
intersection crash scenarios I've just
listed six of them here very very common
this is way all these intersections
occur had nothing much to do with driver
being alert or not alert right it's
really a lot to do with not knowing what
in the world is going on and no way for
you to know so you have to guess okay
this one is not this one you know this
is a red light violation this guy is
moving he's seven seconds into the red
light and it's moving fortunately this
one is alert so he slowed down otherwise
they would have crashed this is a
scenario where there's a limited line of
sight so he's great he comes slowed down
and hits that pedestrian which is a
little bit similar to the accident in
the uber case so what was an intelligent
intersection do basically it would
remove this temporal and spatial
uncertainty that I talked about in there
right and it's present in all those six
scenarios that I discuss our showed so
the first one is to inform the vehicle
the complete signal face not just what
you see but what are the lights
everybody else sees or what movements
are permitted and predict the time of
the next change the second one is to
inform vehicle of potential conflict
zones where you can hit somebody else
right and the third one
is if their blind spots which prevent
you to see what's happening in that
conflict zone right and the last one is
sort of out of that intersection really
is to warn of vehicles making red-light
violations just two ideas of how you
predict when the when the phase is being
changed so let's suppose that you are
these are different phases I won't tell
you what p1 p2 etc means but you're
sitting here or coming here and you want
to make a left turn so you've got to
wait for your signal and currently these
people are going this way p4 and PA so
you want to be able to predict when the
slide is turning red turning green or
conversely these people want to predict
when their green light turns red you
cannot do it I mean these are actuated
signals so that means that the amount of
time that it takes to turn depends upon
how much traffic there isn't you don't
know that right
however you can do a statistical
prediction so if you are interested in
changing p1 then when does p4 end so
that's a random number
random p4 time but you can get it
historically or you can measure it over
the last two days one day hour etc and
produce a probability distribution of
the duration of that particular phase
and then depending on how long you've
been in that phase the intersection can
predict what is the conditional
distribution of the lefting time and so
this is a picture of the conditional
expectation of the remaining duration
it's interesting because it's actuated
it can keep going down and then suddenly
jump up and then keep going down right
so it cannot be simply a countdown timer
which has started and then keep going
down right it's like your files download
goes down and then all of a sudden goes
up so that can be done and the
intersection has enough information to
calculate this thing and either put it
up or broadcast it or whatever let's see
how can you get conflicts so here's the
idea about conflicts so how many
movements are there if I take a four
like an intersection from each approach
you can have three movements left
straight or through its a multiply about
4 that's 12 plus you have similarly 12
bicycle movements so it's 24 and you
have 4 pedestrian movements right so 28
so these are the possible movements that
can happen simultaneously or some of
them simultaneously at any given time so
let's look at somebody who wants to just
make a right turn so that's the
potential trajectory and let's look at
all the ones who are making right turn
so you get what we call a guide way so
that's this blue thing there similarly
other movements right so where to guide
ways come together intersect that's a
potential zone of conflict so the
vehicle wants to make sure that it can
traverse through that potential zone of
conflict ok so let's look at a little
bit closer so we're looking at this
white potential trajectory which this
wants to make how many other conflicts
are there well there's the white
trajectories are other vehicles there's
one and two this vehicle make make a
left turn this vehicle can goes it
doesn't know yet and this is just off
line all the stuff is off line
calculation so there are two there three
there two three back bicycle
trajectories there's a bicycle
trajectory over here with the bicycle
trajectory through and a bicycle left
turn and two questions right so 25 into
7 so there are seven conflicting other
movements that you need to worry about
not all of them can happen because you
have some information from your signal
you have other information from what you
can see so we can eliminate some of
these conflicts okay so let's see what
can be eliminated so these are the seven
conflict zones I'm just drawing them
like that they all sort of bunched
together and those are the potential
movements from other agents so now
you are the ego vehicle they all call
them ego I don't know why but that's ego
ego and there are seven potential other
agents and I've marked them as you want
through you seven use their one through
user seven potential not adversaries but
people you might are agents you might
collide with that so I'm assuming that
this one can already see you 5 u 6 + u 7
and I assume that if you can see them
you can avoid hitting them right so I
eliminate those three possibilities I
assume you can also see you one from
your side you mirror or whatever so for
your all-round radar where all around
camera so we can get a new one u5 u 6
that leaves 3 u 2 u 3 u 4 one of them is
a pedestrian to our vehicles ok vision
whatever system has is obstructed by
this obstacle so cannot see u 2 u 3 u 4
its suspect I mean that is the potential
conflict which is known ahead of time
right because it's simply a geometry
measure so now how in the world can you
resolve u 2 u 3 u 4 what needs
information from the intersection
because right this way it cannot do
anything more right so there are two
intersects two information you can get
number one is what is the phase
everywhere else and number two is if
this is still possible there's a blind
spot then somebody has to tell that
there is something there let's see from
the face he's making a right turn on red
so it sees the red therefore other
signal arrangements which are compatible
with this one seeing red one is red and
movement can go east west and west to
east so that's one possibility it is red
that is red that is red but this one can
go straight then make a left turn that's
not a possibility or the symmetric this
way now
now if it is too so the intersection
tells it that it's two three or four
that gives the complete face so if it's
- that's pretty good
then that's red so none of these can go
so you can see that a lot of the stuff
can be eliminated in the favorable case
where knowing the other phase you can
rule out the movement of u 3 u 4 u 2 and
assume that they are driving legally
right so if that is but if it is still
this one it cannot rule out u 3 u 2 u 4
so now you need information from the
intersection to say what are these blind
spot is occupied or not so I'll leave it
to some designer of sensing on the
intersection to say whether it's
possible or not let's go somewhere so
let's look at the back to the uber crash
this car is turning left it it's in the
way of 1 2 3 4 intersection 4 is the
mister pedestrian crossing so it's in
the way of 4 guideways but these two it
can see are all the stopped so these two
are no longer conflict zones which can
be awakened this one it doesn't know
right because it's empty so that's a
potential conflict zone and I assume
that it can also see over here that
there's there is somebody where there
isn't anybody making the cross so the
only thing is that one right and
let's suppose I'm drawing the situation
as if this were automated instead of the
other it makes no difference so this is
automated so it can see all around and
that's its vision zone this ellipsoid
could be spherical and the other vehicle
is over here so it wants to know whether
there is another vehicle the answer is
it depends if these two guide ways I
occupied which is where it was at this
cars parked over here then you can see
that this area is obstructed so it
cannot tell that there's a vehicle
coming here right so that's ready that's
creates a blind spot which could be
occupied and could lead to an accident
so what is necessary is for this vehicle
to be informed that somebody is occupied
here and conversely for this vehicle to
be informed that somebody's occupying
over here so that's what the sensors
have to do the ways to do this
calculation and to get a reasonably good
idea what it is or is not occupied but I
won't do that
and
[Music]
so I'll skip that if you knew that the
uber vehicle would stop but this this is
the red light violation so the picture I
showed you was this that's part of the
frame that we had a intersection camera
and we took these movies this one way
back and still in during red it's moving
fortunately he is right away obviously
observes that slows down and swerves a
little bit so this one passes through
without a crash this is a bull vehicle
in the same situation
it went through I mean it did not go
through a red light but this truck went
through a red light exactly seven
seconds into the red and hit the Google
car fortunately the driver is on the
other side same thing with the woman and
the uber vehicle was there on the other
side so what's protected but the driver
says he was looking and saw this vehicle
but too late but could easily have been
warned
so these things we you you may have
gotten a red light ticket from a camera
red light violation ticket so the camera
I mean the sensors in the road says that
this vehicle is going at X speed and is
not going to be able to stop here so it
takes several shots of the camera so
that could also be used to warn the
driver or alternatively it could be used
to extend the red light for this part
and allow this one to go through so
that's another possibility it could do
but anyway so it is possible to
ameliorate or mitigate or reduce the
number of red light violations what is
the probability of something happening I
don't know how you do that but here's an
idea so this sort of the Guber scenario
I mean uber scenario so this two lanes
are blocked this one wants to make good
right turn I want to know what's the
problem and there's a somebody coming a
pedestrian and this one cannot see the
pedestrian because it's blocked so
what's the probability of
crash so I'm saying what's the
probability of somebody making a right
turn on red and I'm assuming that this
is a cycle right 2-minute cycle or
whatever during a peak period so there's
a lot this is a high traffic so what's
the probability of somebody trying to
make a right turn on red what's the
probability multiplied by the property
that that are many vehicle or
individuals view is blocked and the
probability that is a pedestrian
crossing at the same time so I'm
assuming that the product of all these
three is the probability of a potential
crash high traffic scenario peak period
several time and see right in on red
probabilities one people on the right
you all want to make oh I'm suing high
traffic there will be blockage so that
probabilities one so probability is what
is the chance of pedestrian crossing
look that's pretty high
except that pedestrians are smart so
they're not going to they will stop
they're not relying on automated things
so the and so that's not number two if
there's a lot of traffic cross
pedestrian traffic this vehicle will
stop I mean you realize that there's a
lot of people crossing in front of you
you stop if there's very few vehicles
are very few pedestrians then this
probability will be small well you will
not stop you will keep going right it's
the intermediate case well this is
reasonably high and you are likely to
make a right turn on red so that's so
summary
Eevee's how many vehicles don't know
intersection phase they cannot predict
when the phase will change they don't
see obscured agents even though they
have perfect sensing right these this
difficulty still remains and so the
intelligent intersection can move the
spatial temporal uncertainty do now if
you want I will has anybody seen that
video so this the video so last Sunday
driver of the uber kill that pedestrian
last Sunday in Tempe the pedestrian was
visible to you and this is a shot
through a dashcam all right so it's a
very poor resolution and you could see
when the thing start and that's the
driver that's the camera of the driver
so you can take a look that I was really
not watching you can see the pedestrian
driver was not watching and finally that
according the driver the profession
appeared from all of a sudden and the
first time she noticed was when it hit
this uber is equipped with lidar
equipped with radar all the way around
equipped with cameras and it cleared
right there's nothing wrong in the scene
and it missed that pedestrian the lidar
did miss the pedestrian but whatever the
the signal processing capabilities
missed the pedestrian so I think it's
way too early yet to have armored
vehicles on the road and expect to have
to call in your uber armored vehicle and
take you somewhere let me stop over here
[Applause]
so if you provide all this information
let's say from intersection wouldn't you
create the sensory or lower low for the
driver that there's too many things to
watch I mean it becomes like
yes no I mean if it's if your automated
you don't care right I mean this is just
very tiny information compared to what
your radar and lidar is seeing it's
trivial second you've seen countdown
timers right for phase change so how do
seing to install a countdown timer in
their cars which will tell you 15 14 13
whatever that's the counter the other
information is the phase that's very I
mean you can if you go to China in on
some streets on some intersections they
provide you the face where which all the
green and all the red are so I don't
think that's difficult but you can
imagine that about blind-spot currently
many cars have blind spot detectors on
their side so this is an additional
blind spot detector which is mobile in
the way and for blind spots which
occurred simply because there's an
obstruction so I'm not sure about that
but certainly there's that's an issue
because the spectrum was allocated by
the FCC and they were the was tremendous
pressure to use that spectrum there was
use it or lose it fear so then it they
did premature standardization and and
now they may be losing that spectrum so
I mean if you talk to Intel they say it
doesn't matter because 5g will take care
[Applause]